happy Friday everybody I'm Peter Brown
here with a gamespot news update as of
this morning a new character for street
fighter 5 has leaked onto the internet
screenshots of newcomer laura were
accidentally shared by japanese
publication from itsu the screenshots
were reportedly shared by mistake when
fitzy was revealing images of returning
character sangee who was announced
officially yesterday laura is a brand
new character to the series and appears
to use electricity in her attacks
according to event hubs a street fighter
fansite the images of her attacks show
influence from Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
the stage shown in the screenshots also
features visual cues pointing to Brazil
as the location Capcom previously
confirmed that there will be four brand
new characters come to street fighter 5
in additional wara the studio previously
announced an Akali and rasheed which
leaves one more brand new character yet
to be revealed street fighter 5 does not
currently have a confirmed release date
but capcom has said that the game will
be out during its current fiscal year
which ends on March 31st 2016 currently
street fighter 5 and development for
playstation 4 and PC and it will allow
for cross-platform play between both
systems for more news on street fighter
5 and its upcoming character
announcement stay tuned to gamespot com
have a good weekend